now we spent weeks talking about the
Labour leadership race but just as it
reaches its conclusion it's been
overtaken by the far more important
issue of coronavirus the pandemic is
dominating everything including the
final weeks of jeremy corbyn's
leadership of the Labour Party mr.
Corbyn joins us now in the studio thank
you very much for being on the show
today
I want to start off with coronavirus and
the health response before we get on to
the economics of it and just to start
off with this graph that we've been
publishing in the Financial Times this
shows the number of deaths from
coronavirus and it shows that the UK
that kind of gray line there is tracking
at a faster rates than Italy which has
already seen more than 4,000 deaths or
Iran as well yeah the USA is steeping up
a bit but it's still well below it okay
I mean given this do you feel that the
government is doing enough
well the clearly much more has to be
done and what this exposes is the
problems in the NHS and so I'm glad that
there's been an arrangement for private
health beds to be now made available off
the NHS but it does indicate just how
damaged our NHS has been by the loss of
beds over the past 10 years
clearly the NHS has got to do absolutely
everything it can and I think we should
just pause for a moment and thank those
NHS staff that are working unbelievably
long hours to try and cope with a crisis
that obviously is not of their making
are you concerned that NHS staff don't
all appear to have the protective
equipment of areas well it's that and
testing the rate of testing we're doing
in this country is far too low and the
World Health Organization have said test
test test we are of increase in the
amount of testing but is still not
enough even all NHS staff haven't been
tested nevermind all care staff haven't
been tested yet and so how can we
accurately know how many cases are
coronavirus there actually are what we
do know
sadly accurately is the number of deaths
from coronavirus at the moment but so we
have to be better at testing and
provision of protective equipment NHS
staff have not all got full protective
equipment at the moment or protective
clothing care staff have almost
none at all and care workers some of
whom work in care homes are obviously at
risk but even more at risk are the care
workers that are going from house to
house of theirs at their clients and
clearly in danger or by the contracting
or spreading the virus you were talking
about the the state of the NHS we
started off with a position where we had
I think 5,000 ventilators around 4,000
intensive care beds do you feel that the
Health Service is prepared for a quite
excited M saying no I don't and I was
talking to Matt Rock of the Fire
Brigades Union who was explained to me
that more than a decade ago was
discussion about threats and dangers to
our society and he said the big one was
actually an unknown virus sweeping this
country as indeed Spanish flu did after
the first world war and so on we are not
prepared for it we were not prepared for
it and surely this is a message that we
have to properly fund our public
services and we have to make sure
everybody has access to good health care
and reasonable state of living otherwise
we're all vulnerable to the
vulnerabilities of the poorest and most
vulnerable in our society the NHS is of
course one of the front lines against
coronavirus base feels as if we all are
part of the front line as well the
actions that we have to take a part of
this battle to we we are you're very
well put we are all the frontline now
and I do urge people I really do listen
listen listen to the advice you're given
don't closely associate with people
don't go places where there's going to
be big crowds and make sure you're not
part of a a big crowd I know all this is
difficult and obviously it's a huge
culture change and I have to say my own
community looking out the windows this
morning the roads are empty the streets
around you okay it was very early but
even so most of yesterday was like that
but it is a massive culture change but
I've also got to think that when people
are told to isolate at home
if you've got a decent place to live and
you're okay that's irritating but not
too bad if you're in a two-bedroom flat
with three kids or four kids and you're
stuck there for weeks on end it's very
very difficult and the stress and
tension that's there is huge so I think
we should also just pay a moment to
thank all those volunteers all over the
country that came out in the past week I
was with a group on Friday who had been
leafletting around my community saying
if you've got you can't get out and you
need medicines picking up and things
like that we're here to help you
and so it's the volunteers they're
coming and yesterday in one of the parks
a a private gym that's closed for
obvious reasons went out in the park and
put their equipment out obviously well
spaced apart said anybody's free to use
it
it's that kind of thing actually there
is a greater sense of community spirit
than I've known for a long time and
that's good and it's gonna be
particularly hard of course for the 1.5
million people that we've just heard
Robert generic talking about those most
at risk who now have been effectively
ordered to stay at home for up to 12
weeks well indeed people that are
ordered to stay at home and don't have
the wherewithal to survive unclear about
how they're going to pay their rent and
they might have been given some
guarantees of no eviction in the
immediate future but it goes on longer
than that but also the very large number
of self-employed I welcome a large part
of the economic package the government
produced on Friday it was the result of
a lot of pressure from the Labour Party
from trade unions and employers
organizations lots of people put
pressure on them but for the
self-employed it is very very difficult
their self employment covers lots of
things some self-employed people quite
well-off a lot of self-employed people
and not it's a very marginal existence
and if they're told to stay home and all
they can access possibly is benefits
through a universal credit they've got
to sign up to get it it won't come
straightaway they are vulnerable
therefore they've got to put food on the
table
isn't it right to cut the government a
bit of slack here it's a very
fast-moving situation as you say
self-employment is is a whole range of
different levels of income and
situations
they need a bit more time to work
something out that's fair enough isn't
it
listen I understand the problems are
working all this stuff out we've had
meetings with the Prime Minister we have
meetings with the Chancellor we've had
meetings with a lot of Ministers and we
had a meeting of all party leaders on
Friday evening as well most most of
these meetings are done by conference
calling and so on I fully understand all
the stresses and problems associated
with of course I get that but the danger
is here now and present if you're
self-employed electrician you've got to
keep your family fed and you normally
bring in five hundred seven hundred
thousand pound a week whatever you
suddenly told you've gotta get nothing
and you cannot go out you've got bills
to pay and the same not everybody's
gonna do it so I'm just saying the
government's got to give a message at a
signal which they haven't given about
raising statutory sick pay or about the
self-employed there are millions of
people working self-employed now in
Britain has changed the package
announced by Irish EC net was
unprecedented
eighty percent of people's wages the
government is prepared to step in and
pay John MacDonald's reaction the Shadow
Chancellor was I think he needs to go a
lot further and a lot faster I mean some
people listening to it might be thinking
couldn't speak it just sounds like
Labour's moaning what John also said
that he welcomed the direction of the
package he welcomed a lot of it the
point he was making was that some
employers and already there's evidence
of this and not paying the other 20% so
it's a 20 percent wage cut or they're
laying people off rather than accept the
package that the government's given
because clearly the economy needs to be
strong for recovery after coronavirus
but I have to say of course it's a huge
step forward and the amount of money
that has now been found to invest in our
economy is great is huge and it's what I
was condemned for asking for to deal
with austerity and poverty in Britain
three months ago you talked about the
election that yes some people would say
it slightly different times of course
it's different times but we just have to
recognize a society ten years of
austerity has left us a bit vulnerable
say you won the argument you think I
don't to relive every past debate all
I'm saying is
the principle of caring for everybody in
our society is now absolutely center
stage and so we understand all of our
vulnerabilities and our dependence on
each other and saying I think as a
society we're going to be stronger at
the end of this not weaker I'm talking
about being stronger not weaker at the
end and we've been talking a lot about
the people who've done good those in the
NHS those people helping out in their
communities to look after their
vulnerable but we've also seen scenes of
people still going to the pub last
Friday night people go down to Skegness
for a holiday people stop piling in the
supermarkets are you worried that people
some people are acting selfishly there
are unfortunately aspects of human
nature that are appalling
one of them is greed and so they go into
a supermarket they've got a big balance
on their credit card so they can afford
to take all the fish all the beans all
the bread of everything far more than
they could possibly consume in a month
or two leaving other people with nothing
and so you hear some horrible arguments
that have gone on in supermarkets but
and you also hear some heroic work done
by supermarket managers I was talking to
what last night the local store to me
and he has run his store extremely well
what he's done is given the time when
pensioners and vulnerable people can
come in and so on and so on and he's
looking at and he's not letting anybody
buy more than one item I think he's fine
I think that's the way it should be and
so I do say to people there's no need to
stockpile all you're doing is actually
making it harder for those that don't
have the ready cash that you've got so
just be reasonable and be fair about it
now also to other shops don't start
jacking up your prices the wholesale
prices have not gone up and there's some
profiteering going on and that has to be
addressed now we're all having to make
changes to our lives that a couple of
weeks ago we could never have imagined
you're 17 you're in the high-risk
category what changes are you having to
make to your own life well I'm obviously
working and I'm a local MP as well as
leader of the party I'm making sure I'm
not getting too close to people which is
why I didn't even shake your hand this
morning as though it's the normal thing
to do
and also making sure that everything's
kept absolutely clean and I think as a
whole country we should say thank you to
all the cleaners is it all over the
country should you still be going to
Parliament for example well that's a
difficult one and we have discussed this
with the speaker and with the
authorities and the compromise we
reached last week was firstly that I
think Parliament should remain in
session it's very important that we have
the chance to put questions to the
government and of course this
legislation is going to come up on
Monday but what we agreed was informally
between the parties we'd greatly reduce
the number of MPs that came into the
chamber they would have to sit one to
two metres apart and so Prime Minister's
question time last Wednesday was a very
strange experience all the galleries
were completely empty and there were
only less than a hundred MPs in the
whole chamber all well spaced out the
atmosphere was like something I've never
known before I know you're going to
continue going to Parliament though yes
of course because I've got to speak
there and I've got to ask the questions
there but again we've reduced a number
of people in my office as low as we
possibly can and they're working from
home and we've we're all getting very
good at zoom calls and conference
calling okay now it feels strange almost
to talk about your legacy as Labour
leader because coronavirus has dominated
everything has changed everything but at
the same time it is one of your first
interview since the election you coming
to the end of your tenure as leader and
so it feels right to ask a bit about
that as well
do you feel like it was a successful
period for the Labour Party well
unfortunately didn't win the last
election in that of course the last two
elections or two elections we came very
close in 17 but 19 I get there obviously
I'm very sad at that what I think has
happened as the Labour Party has
absolutely addressed the issues of
economic security and justice in Britain
in the 2015 election we were promising a
lighter form of austerity rather than
the complete end to it what we've done
is become a party of economic inclusion
and I'm proud of that we're also a very
much larger membership there ever was
it's gone up by from 200,000 to almost
600,000 whilst I've been lead
and I wrote a email to all party members
of weekly oh saying please get involved
in your local community please go out
and do everything you can to help people
we've got six hundred thousand people to
do that and I had a big zoom call on
Friday night with lots of members and
they fed back to me what they're doing
in their communities we've become a more
community-based organization and we've
changed the agenda on the economy
changed the agenda on social justice
change the agenda on the green
Industrial Revolution and environmental
sustainability so there's many things
I'm very proud someone listened to what
you've just been saying I think there's
not enough admission of what went wrong
I mean we can have a look here this is
the how the labor of John historically
in labor election results since nineteen
thirty five you can see that you led the
party to the worst defeat in 85 years
you lost two elections yeah you also
became just a second political party
after the BNP to be investigated by the
equality and Human Rights Commission I
mean many people will think that this
was not something to be proud of it was
a disastrous period Felisha we had
unprecedented attacks made against us
I'm proud of the economic agenda we put
forward and I think we've achieved a
great deal in changing the agenda on
that and I'm proud about that obviously
I am very disappointed by the election
result in the end the 2019 election was
the brexit election I recognize there
are passionate feelings to remain there
are passionate feelings for leave I had
to bridge that gap amongst party
supporters as well as party members and
I did my best to do that by offering the
arrangement of a deal with the EU and a
second referendum until it clearly that
wasn't something that finally was
achieved but the Prime Minister fought
the election campaign saying he'd get
brexit done he hasn't got a trade deal
with the USA he hasn't got a trade deal
with us been dealing with a global
pandemic that not many kind things I
absolutely absolutely
of course I appreciate that so
everything's gonna have to be put on
hold because at the moment the whole
world has got a deal with this global
pandemic and we've got to recognize that
global health inequalities as well as
national health inequalities are a
danger to all of us and so as party
leader I'm proud of our members proud of
the way we've developed
great greater democracy in the party and
some of the more democratic procedures
that have been introduced but clearly
there's a long way to go you talk there
about changing the agenda means which of
the leadership contenders do you think
is best place to continue your legacy
listen they vote they fought a good
campaign they've had great debates all
of them I know them all very well at
various times they've all been in the
shadow cabinet
they've all been appointed by me some
resigned another student to resigned and
one didn't say is should we conclude
that the one who didn't ensure what you
should conclude is that I am determined
that our party remains an anti-austerity
party remains dedicated increasing human
rights away if you're in labor member
trying to work out who the best person
is to do that what would you say to them
what would save them is think through
what you want for our party in our
society think through who's going to
carry forward the anti austerity agenda
but think through also the needs of
strengthened democracy within our party
and I tell you what I'm going to be very
busy doing campaigning work on economy
on human rights and environmental issues
I am NOT disappearing from anywhere if
you're not disappearing is there a
particular Shadow Cabinet role that you
got your eye on well I've always spent
my life trying to deal with issues of
human rights and justice around the
world and that is something whether I
have a position or not is not important
what's important is that we use the
honor of holding public office to hold
executives to account but also to hold
the unaccountable to account for those
that are fighting their human rights
shadow for a secretary are you
suggesting something Jeremy Corbyn thank
you very much thank you very program
today thank you